a new decade is upon us and hollywood's
major studios have lined up a slew of
projects to compete for your film going
dollar
some of the upcoming releases on the
calendar are highly anticipated sequels
but that isn't all we're expecting to
see
even though the initial teaser arrived
way back in december 2019 we still know
very little about the plot of
christopher nolan's upcoming action epic
tenet which is slated for release on
august 12
2020. of course that date has changed a
few times already and may change again
due to the coronavirus pandemic
it's reversing the flow of time
it wasn't us being here now and it never
happened
we do know that it's an expensive
production with the budget reportedly
clocking in at about 225 million dollars
on top of that the sci-fi thriller was
filmed with imax cameras so expect
big things literally the film stars john
david washington aaron taylor johnson
and robert pattinson among others
pattinson told usa today in april 2019
that he had been sworn to secrecy
regarding the details of tennant's plot
the actor was fond of the script however
and said nolan changed his mind about
doing big budget movies explaining
i've been a little wary of doing big
movies for years and years but there's
just something about chris nolan's stuff
he seems like the only director now who
can do what is essentially a very
personal independent movie that has huge
scale
i read the script and it's unreal new
life was breathed into the zombie genre
in 2016 with trained
busan a korean horror film written and
directed by young sang-ho that followed
a group of passengers trapped on a train
as a zombie virus spread quickly through
its cars
the film is action-packed funny and
terrifying all at once
with fully realized characters and a
simple yet well-executed story
it garnered a slew of award wins and
nominations and is generally regarded as
one of the best zombie films of recent
years
four years later yan is returning to the
story with peninsula which is set in an
evacuated and apparently abandoned korea
now completely overrun by the undead the
film follows jung suk a former marine
who takes a job that sends him into the
blighted country
once they get there he and his team are
met not only with zombies but a group of
survivors who have made the most of the
epidemic by turning it into
entertainment
peninsula isn't just a follow-up to
train to busan it's an over-the-top
expansion of the universe young created
in 2016.
as the filmmaker explained to screen
daily in march 2020
the scale of peninsula can't compare to
train to busan it makes it look like an
independent film
trendy busan was a high concept film
shot in narrow spaces where his
peninsula has a much wider scope of
movement
as such it carries a much larger price
tag 16 million dollars nearly double
what its predecessor had to work with
it looks as though its money was well
spent however peninsula appears to be
twice as crazy as trained to busan was
disney is set to turn another one of
their most popular animated films into a
live-action epic in 2020 debuting an
updated version of mulan
the movie which was initially set to be
released in 2018 but later pushed back
will be directed by nikki cairo based on
a script from rick jaffa and amanda
silver
the remake received positive reviews and
early screening but was hit with a last
minute delay due to the coronavirus
outbreak
i will never give up the initial delay
in the film's release date reportedly
happened because it took disney a year
of searching across the world to find
its star
they eventually landed on chinese
actress ipe liu also known as crystal
lou
lou is one of china's most popular
actresses who has been nicknamed fairy's
sister due to her innocent seeming
public persona
with the lead warrior princess in plays
the cast was rounded out with
international stars jet li donnie yen
and jason scott lee
party on dudes for we are truly living
through a bonafide keanassance thanks in
no small part to the ongoing success of
the john wick series rumors have been
bouncing around hollywood about
potential sequels and reboots for
everything from the matrix to speed
one keanu-centric follow-up that's
definitely coming is bill and ted face
the music
a hopefully fantastic voyage following
in the radical footsteps of 1989's
excellent adventure and 1991's bogus
journey
after many years of rumblings keanu
reeves and alex winter officially
confirmed in a video in march of 2019
that strange things were indeed afoot at
the circle k
once again william sadler came back to
reprise his role as the grim reaper and
original writers chris matheson and ed
solomon also returned to penn the
screenplay with galaxy quest director
dean pariso also signing on to see the
movie through
the sequel will catch up with the now
middle-aged bill s preston and theodore
logan as they realize that adult
responsibilities like fatherhood have
prevented them from coming up with the
universe saving song that they were
destined to write
they will be assisted by their daughters
in their long-awaited third quest
and will once again come face to face
with death remember to be excellent to
each other when you line up for your
tickets
be excellent to each other and party on
dudes
dare we even talk about the new mutants
as a 2020 release
at this rate assigning an actual date to
the seemingly cursed x-men project
is like waiting for a toad to get struck
by lightning after an initial trailer
was released in the bygone days of
october 2017 the movie has been pushed
back no fewer than four times
shifting from april 2018 to february
2019 then to august 2019
the release of disney's post fox merger
schedule revealed that new mutants had
been delayed yet again
all the way to april 3 2020. just when
all seemed to be finally going well for
the film it became one of many projects
delayed by the coronavirus pandemic
so other than the latest one what's
behind all the delays
by all accounts it's not actually the
quality of the film itself
unlike dark phoenix new mutants has
reportedly been well received in test
screenings
the movie's source comics created in the
1980s by chris claremont and bill
cintkevich remain
unique fan favorites the cast features
up and comers like the witches anya
taylor joy and game of thrones as maisie
williams
it's apparently a number of outside
factors that have kept the film from
coming out from conflicts with the
release date of deadpool 2
a decision to play up the movie's horror
elements with reshoots that reportedly
didn't even end up happening and the
earth shaking disney fox merger
hopefully we'll actually be able to
watch the new mutants in 2020
and hopefully it will live up to its
potential as a stylish and frightening
final fox x-men movie
in 2018 a quiet place took hollywood by
surprise turning a modest 17 million
dollar budget around to pull in nearly
350 million dollars worldwide at the box
office
it's also one of the most highly
acclaimed horror films in recent years
with rotten tomatoes granting it an
overwhelming fresh rating and calling it
a quote
ruthlessly intelligent creature feature
that's as original as it is scary
so it's no wonder paramount pitchers
would want to capitalize with a sequel
a quiet place part 2 was initially
slated to hit theaters on march 20th
2020 but was delayed at the last minute
due to the coronavirus pandemic
while writer director john krasinski is
confirmed for the sequel now it wasn't
always that way
in an interview with the ringers the big
picture podcast krazynski said he
initially didn't want to have anything
to do with the second film but was
convinced by his producer to jot down a
few ideas
and then after like three weeks he was
like why don't you just write this and
then we'll get another filmmaker like
just
and of course jedi mind tricked me into
signing onto the
sequel as far as the story goes writer
scott beck and brian woods knew that
there was the potential to focus on new
families krzezinski seemed to agree that
the sequel wouldn't be just about the
habits of the original telling the
hollywood reporter
in our circumstance the thing that the
audience loved most was the world that's
the cool thing that you could explore on
and on
2017's wonder woman is the most
critically acclaimed movie in the dc
extended universe by a wide margin
it makes sense then that gal gadot's
embodiment of the amazonian warrior is
being fast-tracked back to the big
screen
while superman and batman are left to
fight a legion of issues standing in the
way of their next movie appearance
she with you i love cheers with you
diana's second solo adventure hasn't
been without delays of its own however
the movie was pushed back from its
original 2019 holiday season release to
june 5th 2020
and then to october due to the
coronavirus when the movie does arrive
it will bring with it the blast from the
past promised by its title
filling in part of the timeline between
the first movies world war one setting
and the hero's reemergence in batman vs
superman dawn of justice
wonder woman 1984 will see the return of
gadot chris pine robin wright and
director patty jenkins
snl alum kristen wiig joins the prey as
nemesis cheetah while the mandalorians
pedro pascal pulls the strings as evil
tycoon maxwell lord
marvel studios was originally set to
release black widow its 24th film in the
beginning of the mcu's phase 4 on may
1st but that date got pushed back 6
months
the shift wound up affecting not only
black widow but the rest of marvel's
phase 4 projects as well
chronologically the film will still take
place between captain america civil war
and avengers infinity war
in it scarlett johansson's natasha
romanov sets off to confront her past
than the people she left behind when she
traded her first family for the avengers
family big together again according to
its cast the film is going to be
something of a departure from other
marvel properties
it's a little dirty it's all salty
i like olive oil uh yeah it's it's it's
like bringing some realness to the
marble universe
joining johansen or david harbor is
alexi aka red guardian florence pugh is
natasha's fellow black widow agent elena
and rachel vice as molina
a character who's reportedly been
through the widow program five times
after several development setbacks
including daniel craig's uncertain
return to the franchise following 2015
spectre the latest bond film was
scheduled for wide release on april 8th
unfortunately its troubles weren't over
as the movie would become the first
major film industry victim of
coronavirus concerns
leading to an eight-month delay
announced in march it's just one of the
many ways in which getting bond back on
screen has proven to be a challenge i
need a favor brother
you're the only one i trust for this
late in 2018 the film's original
director danny boyle left the project
due to a script dispute
only a month later true detectives
carrie fukanaga signed on in his place
but boyle's departure wound up setting
the film's release date back six months
while no time to die will officially
mark frank's final film as james bond it
will reportedly introduce a brand new
double 07 to the franchise
returning cast members include christoph
waltz ben wishaw leia sudhu naomi harris
jeffrey wright and rape fines
new to the film are lashanna lynch as a
fresh double o agent and rami malik who
will portray the movie's villain
no time to die is set some time after
bond is retired from active service
he's called back when the cia needs help
with a mysterious villain armed with
dangerous new technology
frank herbert's 1965 novel dune has had
a towering
influence over the world of science
fiction which is probably why filmmakers
have been trying to bring herbert's
universe to the screen for decades
avant-garde director alejandro
yodorowski's ambitious but abandoned
attempt in the 70s was so legendary it
eventually became the subject of a hit
documentary
david lynch held the blockbuster version
of dune in 1984 but while the film has
something of a cult following many
including lynch himself found it
unsatisfying a sci-fi mini-series in
2000 served as a fateful adaptation but
suffered from the limitations of a tv
budget
now a rival and blade runner 2049
director denis villeneuve hopes to get
it right
his strongest asset so far is an already
stacked cast
which includes timothy chalamet rebecca
ferguson dave bautista stellen skarsgard
oscar isaac zendaya
javier bardem josh brolin and jason
momoa another point in the productions
favor the film will reportedly focus on
only the first half of herbert's novel
avoiding the overstuffed confusion of
the lynch movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]